et voilà c'était le grand jour de la
prison à l'Odéon un film indispensable
réalisé par Guy Bochet bonjour qui nous
fait l'honneur de participer à Z la Zone
d'Éducation documentaire et juste avant
côté on accueille Mouloud Mansouri
bonjour vous êtes producteur de musique
avec votre association foujeau vous
organisez des concerts des ateliers
d'écriture dans des prisons depuis plus
de 10 ans et en octobre dernier vous
avez même sorti le deuxième opus de la
Star Academy un album réalisé avec des
détenus voilà deux expériences humaines
et artistiques que vous allez nous
raconter nous décrypter grâce aux
questions des élèves du lycée Jean-Paul
de roccassera ici à Porto-Vecchio
bonjour les élèves
alors je sais que vous avez beaucoup de
questions vous avez beaucoup travaillé
sur ce documentaire mais juste avant
j'aimerais vous demander une chose quand
on vous dit quand vous entendez le mot
prison qu'est-ce qui vous vient tout de
suite à l'esprit oui
le danger la peur néo d'autres mots qui
vous viennent comme ça oui l'égalité ok
et vous guibauchez avant d'y mettre
votre caméra dans la prison si je vous
avais demandé une image ça aurait été
laquelle c'est un peu l'image qu'on voit
souvent les les séries américaines ou
les fictions c'est-à-dire quelque chose
d'un peu parfois terrifiant quoi et un
peu dur alors qu'en fait
moi j'ai découvert que c'était pas que
ça en fait
monts vous avez vous-même été détenus
pour trafic de drogue pendant 10 ans
est-ce que est-ce que vous vous rappelez
vous de votre premier jour en fait
j'étais rentré dans une cellule où je
devais attendre genre une cellule
d'attente ou là je me suis dit waouh je
vais passer
des années là dedans là elle était crade
c'était pas la cellule qu'on a qu'on
avait après pour vivre dedans mais je me
suis dit ça va être chaud de survivre là
dedans encore une image qui vous revient
tu vois la pochette de hashtar Academy
elle est très très sombre c'est ce que
ça représente la prison c'est un endroit
un endroit vraiment
allez on va passer à vos questions
maintenant et on commence avec
Jean-Baptiste
comment l'idée de votre documentaire
a-t-elle vu le jour
et en fait je suivais le travail de
Sylvie nordem en fait depuis pas mal de
temps j'en avais entendu parler et moi
je trouvais ça super intéressant
justement de de changer de regard en
fait sur la prison et sur les détenus
est-ce que en regardant le documentaire
de Guy Bochet
vous vous êtes reconnu dans la
personnalité de Sylvie ou peut-être même
dans certains détenus dans votre dans
votre passé c'est toujours cool
d'échanger avec des gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur parce que tu as pas le même
échange qu'avec un code détenu donc du
coup c'est souvent plus intéressant et
plus enrichissant pour le détenu et donc
quel que soit l'intervenant qui vient en
général moi ça me rappelle ça quand je
croisais des gens d'extérieur j'avais
tout de suite tu vois échanger avec eux
et m'imprégner un peu des choses qui
venaient de l'extérieur personne sait
que ce qui se passe dans les prisons et
ça fasse il y a des ateliers des
concerts des projets qui s'organisent
parce qu'en fait vraiment la prison
c'est un lieu clos tu vois c'est presque
les oubliettes la prison on continue
avec Baptiste comment vos projets
ont-ils été acceptés par les différents
acteurs de la prison c'est à dire les
détenus le personnel pénitentiaire ainsi
que la direction de la prison
il y a un cahier des charges qui est
très précis sur ce qu'on a le droit de
faire ce qu'on a le droit de filmer ce
qu'on a pas le droit de filmer
[Musique]
sur le matériel qu'on doit faire rentrer
sur le nombre de personnes qui ont le
droit de rentrer c'est extrêmement
contrôlé une fois que vous vous avez
passé ce cap les choses se passent si
vous respectez les règles ça se passe
plutôt bien après au niveau des détenus
ça c'est très bien passé c'est à dire
qu'il y a il y a toujours une période un
peu d'observation qui est logique et
voilà c'est une période d'acceptation et
puis et puis après quand les gens ont
compris que vous êtes là pour mettre en
valeur leur travail leur personnalité
ce que les gens ont envie de dire et
d'exprimer après ça se passe très bien
en fait c'est comme avec tout le monde
finalement ça change pas grand-chose
donc on connaisse un peu mon travail et
pour ceux qui connaissaient pas bah non
c'est assez simple ils savent qu'on
vient pour eux et à partir du moment où
ils savent que c'est un projet vraiment
qui va dans leur direction
eux ils en profitent quels ont été les
principales difficultés que vous avez
rencontré pour mener à bien vos projets
respectifs c'est-à-dire quand tu passes
les portes entre le moment où tu arrives
devant la prison et le moment où les
détenus arrivent dans la salle
c'est-à-dire déjà nous ça peut prendre
du temps pour rentrer sas de sécurité
que tout le monde tu vois par exemple
quand tu entreprends c'est 6 par 6 déjà
ça va pas vite et après une fois que tu
as passé tous les contrôles souvent les
détenus ils sont pas appelés c'est
beaucoup de travail aussi d'aller
chercher des tenues qui sont parfois en
plus qui vont avoir des rendez-vous soit
avec des conseillers d'orientation soit
ils vont avoir un rendez-vous au parloir
donc en fait pour rassembler tout le
monde c'est hyper long après l'autre moi
ma difficulté ça a été aussi ce lieu
unique fermé clos j'ai pas pu aller dans
les cellules
et en même temps c'était une contrainte
intéressante en termes de de mise en
scène parce qu'il a fallu que je me
débrouille avec cet endroit avec
énormément de réverbération
des murs très froids bon voilà c'est
c'était aussi ça qui était un peu un peu
difficile pouvez-vous nous expliquer
votre parti pris technique en ce qui
concerne votre réalisation je me permets
même de compléter il y a des plans très
très serrés qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
moi j'aime ça déjà en fait j'adore
j'adore filmer les visages donc il y a
une émotion qui passe souvent à travers
le regard et en gros plan je trouve que
c'est extrêmement fort moi je possède
des mecs qui avaient des gueules qui
avaient des vraiment des très beaux
regards des très belles expressions donc
ça me paraissait normal en fait de
mettre de mettre tout ça en valeur c'est
aussi comme ça que moi j'ai réussi je
pense à créer une certaine proximité
avec mes personnages c'est-à-dire qu'à
un moment donné
à force de me voir deux fois trois fois
par semaine passer beaucoup de temps
avec eux il y a le temps du tournage et
puis il y a le temps de la discussion
avant qu'ils rentrent c'est important
documentaire d'avoir la confiance des
gens des gens que vous filmez donc cette
confiance
quand vous êtes seul ça aide aussi pas
mal
alors moi j'aurais une question pour
vous guibochez si vous deviez choisir un
moment de votre documentaire lequel
sélectionneriez-vous et pourquoi
c'est difficile
en fait il y a un moment qui m'a
vraiment touché c'est quand bamzi
apprend que
il est pas retenu il a pas le droit de
sortir pour aller jouer à l'Odéon
c'était dur parce que lui c'était un
personnage très fort du film ça c'était
c'était assez émouvant et après il y a
évidemment
la représentation la représentation
c'est un moment fort parce que parce que
c'est des gars qui arrivent dans un
milieu qui l'aurait complètement inconnu
un milieu qui va peut-être avoir des a
priori sur eux et puis une espèce de
magie qui prend une innovation pour un
travail qui a duré trois mois qui leur a
demandé quand même beaucoup beaucoup
d'efforts il y a du bruit on des
dérangés il y a des coups détenus il
fait froid il y a des punaises de lit il
y a plein de problèmes en fait qui
viennent parasiter donc c'est vrai que
la récompense de la de la de la
représentation et l'innovation de la fin
c'est un moment hyper fort et vous quel
a été la séquence qui vous a le plus
marqué peut-être à la fin avec Axel qui
revoit son père et ça je pense qu'on a
tous été quand même moi je dirais c'est
là où l'administration il devait valider
les dossiers de ceux qui pouvaient aller
à l'Odéon et ceux qui pouvaient pas et
des fois on pouvait même si on des fois
on voyait pas les visages de ceux qui
pouvaient pas aller à l'Odéon on
imaginait la peine qui devait avoir
puisqu'ils ont travaillé dur pour ce
projet qu'au final tous ces crawl on
enchaîne avec toi Laetitia en quoi le
projet de l'acheteur Academy peut-il
participer à la réinsertion des détenus
c'est très simple ça c'est un album qui
est signé en maison de disque et c'est
un vrai travail professionnel pour eux
donc
un accès à la culture l'accès à tout le
matériel qu'on peut qu'on peut dont on
peut avoir besoin pour enregistrer un
album tous les intervenants qui sont qui
sont là pour eux à échanger avec eux
travailler avec eux travailler le mal à
la scène comment se tenir etc en fait on
les a préparés à être des professionnels
de la musique
on poursuit avec Ella comment les
détenus ont-ils été sélectionnés et ce
qui avait d'autres critères de sélection
que leur talent musical et est-ce que
l'administration pénitentiaire ou les
autorités judiciaires avaient un droit
de regard ou un avis sur la question
c'est d'abord l'administration
présidentielle qui a fait un premier tri
parce qu'il fallait qu'on ait des mecs
condamnés
qui soient pas criminel pas avec des
victimes parce qu'on allait faire de la
promo on allait dans on allait voir les
les artistes détenus dans les clips et
tout et ça peut poser problème vis-à-vis
des victimes donc moi j'avais demandé
ces critères là
et donc ils a fait une ils ont fait une
présélection et après on les a cassés
j'ai eu 70 tenue et donc il y en a qu'on
a choisi parce qu'il savait râpé un peu
et il y en a parce qu'ils avaient des
bonnes gueule ils avaient du bagout ils
pouvaient apporter autre chose que de
faire de la musique mais tu vois booster
booster les mecs qui seraient sur
l'album donner des idées qui soient
motivés et qui ce qu'ils aient un vrai
rapport avec la musique quand même outre
cet album de rap quelles sont les autres
ateliers et activités qui ont été menées
y a-t-il d'autres domaines que la
musique je fais beaucoup d'ateliers de
DJ de Closer de stand-up de street art
plein plein d'ateliers là je vais
essayer de me mettre un peu à la cuisine
on va essayer de faire un top hips un
Top Chef en prison mais encore une fois
beaucoup de concerts on continue à Chloé
le rap étant un style musical qui peut
avoir une image négative auprès d'une
partie de la population à cause
notamment de certaines paroles qui
peuvent être etc pensez-vous que la
réalisation d'un album de rap est au
final le meilleur moyen de changer
l'image des détenus
moi je cherche pas à changer l'image des
détenus ma culture c'est le rap c'est la
musique que je connais et que je sais
faire donc j'interviens avec ce projet
là Émilie
[Musique]
monsieur
des critiques ou des reproches
concernant le point de vue que vous avez
adopté envers les détenus mais aussi
envers la prison dans votre documentaire
c'est à dire que la prison ne doit pas
rimer uniquement avec punition et
sanctions
en fait ce film là je l'ai pas fait je
me suis pas dit tiens je vais
révolutionner la vision des que les gens
peuvent avoir des détenus j'ai eu des
retours négatifs évidemment parce qu'il
y a toujours des gens qui pensent que la
prison c'est un endroit où on doit punir
des gens alors punir des gens ça veut
dire leur retirer toutes les
distractions il y a toujours des gens
qui pensent qu'un détenus c'est un mec
qui doit galérer en fait voilà les
peines justement des des personnages
dans votre documentaire à dessin ou pas
et puis je les connais pas et puis ça
m'intéresse pas en fait
moi j'ai à faire à des gars qui font un
atelier théâtre et j'ai envie de les
prendre comme ça on poursuit donc avec
elle on peut comprendre que ce type
d'initiative donc la réalisation d'un
projet de drap ou des détenus qui jouent
à l'Odéon puisse déranger ou choquer des
personnes comme des victimes mais du
coup si vous en aviez une actuellement
devant vous qu'est-ce que vous pourriez
lui dire pour la convaincre de l'utilité
de ces projets culturels en prison
moi je dirais que c'est important
d'accompagner
le détenu qui qui a peut-être agressé
cette personne ou je ne sais pas
pour la rendre meilleure que ce qu'elle
était avant si on fait rien pour cette
personne et que on essaie pas de
l'insérer ou de la réinsérer la prison
aura servi à rien pourquoi est-il plus
difficile de travailler en prison
maintenant qu'avant en ce moment c'est
plus difficile
d'accompagner des projets en prison mais
mais là encore plus aujourd'hui là
depuis l'histoire quantès un karting
dans une cour de prison est-ce qu'on
peut concevoir que ça puisse choquer
l'opinion publique et de gens justement
qui ne connaissent pas l'univers
carcéral
sur cette sur cette polémique quand je
vais vous lire le commentaire d'érection
outil donc député les républicains qui
dit nos prisons ne sont pas des colonies
de vacances moi c'est mon préféré c'est
dire comment vous réagissez à ça
à passer 24 heures
derrière les barreaux dans une cellule à
manger la gamelle et dormir dans les
conditions qu'on peut avoir à Fresnes et
puis après on se revoit et on fait une
discussion et je pense qu'il aura pas du
tout le même avis quand vous en avez
entendu parler tout le monde a entendu
parler de cette polémique qu'est-ce que
vous vous êtes dit néo
disait si bien en fait on entend jamais
parler de la prison en temps normal et
que les personnes pourraient pas
qu'elles entendent parler de la prison
et croient du coup que les prisonniers
s'amusent en fait le problème c'est plus
que la prison c'est un sujet tabou et du
coup tout le monde pense qu'il s'amuse
alors pas du tout c'est rare mais ce
genre de exceptionnel ce genre
d'occasion
à vos projets il y a de l'instruction
derrière alors que là on est plus juste
en quelque chose de divertissement je
peux comprendre qu'il est victime qui
voit par exemple son agresseur en prison
en train de faire un karting je peux
comprendre que ça puisse choquer ou même
blesser la personne en question parce
que tu te dis qu'il a pas forcément été
puni pour revenir à
la vision des hommes politiques sur la
prison c'était personne
je pense qu'il y a aussi quelque chose
de très électoraliste et à un moment
donné
on fait le buzz en sortant effectivement
un extrait comme ça qui aurait pu être
un extrait du théâtre ou un extrait de
de construire
et on en fait quelque chose qui va
servir une cause politique mais en fait
c'est tout c'est faire du buzz est-ce
que ce film le film de Guy Bochet a
changé votre regard sur la prison
moi je voulais dire que quand on pense à
la prison pour souvent à des personnes
méchantes froides et quand on voit
qu'ils sont en train de Kelly par
exemple quand tu lis son texte on voit
qu'il rigole qu'il arrive pas et que on
voit très bien qu'il est pas méchant et
qu'au fond c'est pas parce qu'ils sont
en prison qu'il faut les dévaloriser il
y a des méchants méchants quand même ah
oui ça arrive
vision de la prison enfin on en parle
pas c'est limite tabou et je pense que
c'est une bonne chose parce que ça peut
ouvrir les yeux enfin de certaines
personnes surtout quand elles ont des
préjugés vraiment définies sur si tu es
en prison c'est que tu es une mauvaise
personne et c'est pas forcément ça donc
voilà moi je voulais dire que ma vision
elle a surtout changé pas au niveau de
la prison mais surtout des prisonniers
parce que c'est vrai qu'on les imagine
plus froid renfermés sur eux-mêmes tout
ça se battre entre eux et je pensais pas
pour être honnête qui se bougeait autant
pour avancer et que on voit qu'ils ont
vraiment fait des efforts ça m'a donné
une meilleure vision de globalement on
va s'arrêter là-dessus je pense que
c'est pas mal bravo merci merci beaucoup
à tous les deux merci à vous de m'enfuir
et à Guy Bocher merci à vous les élèves
vous pouvez aussi vous applaudir et puis
sans oublier votre professeur
d'histoire-géo votre professeur
documentaliste qui nous ont permis de
fabriquer ce magnifique programme on se
retrouve très vite avec une nouvelle
classe et un nouveau documentaire parce
qu'il n'y a pas d'âge pour questionner
le monde et ces allez salut
[Musique]